AS WELL.
A WOMAN WHO WAS BORN IN THE
U.S. AND LEFT THE COUNTRY TO
FIGHT FOR ISIS IS TONIGHT
BEGGING TO COME BACK HOME
CORRESPONDENT BENJAMIN HALL
SPOKE WITH HODA WHO IS NOW
IN A REFUGEE CAMP IN
NORTHERN SYRIA.
>> IN THE DYING DAYS OF THE
CALIPHATE, THOUSAND OF ISIS
FAMILIES FLED INTO THE
SYRIAN DESSERT TRYING TO
ESCAPE.
AMONG THEM WHO HE
AMONG HHEM WHO HE
AMONG HODM WHO HE
AMONG HODOMWHO HE
AMONG HODOM WO HE
AMONG HODOM WHOHE
AMONG HODOM WHO WAS BORN IN
AMERICA AND WENT TO SYRIA
AND REGRETS IT?
>> I WANT MY SON TO SEE HIS
FAMILY.
>> THE U.S. SAYS MUTHANA IS
NOT AND HAS NEVER BEEN A
U.S. CITIZEN HER FATHER WAS
A YEMENI DIPLOMAT AT THE
TIME OF HER BIRTH.
SHE LIVED IN HOOVER, ALABAMA
AND CLAIMS SHE WAS
RADICALIZED ONLINE.
IN 2014, ISIS WAS COMMITTING
HORRIBLE ATROCITIES.
19-YEAR-OLD MUTHANA LEFT THE
U.S. TO JOIN THEM.
>> YOU TURNED YOUR BACK ON
AMERICA.
WHY?
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> YOU GOT TO DO BETTER THAN
THAT HAVE YOU GOT TO EXPLAIN
WHY YOU MADE THIS DECISION.
>> BUT SHE COULDN'T EXCEPT
NO COMMENT AND ALWAYS THAT
LAUGHTER AND DENIAL SHE
HATED AMERICA.
>> I DIDN'T HATE AMERICA.
I DIDN'T HATE -- I JUST
THOUGHT [INAUDIBLE]
SHE MARRIED THREE ISIS
FIGHTERS.
HAD A CHILD AND BECAME
MOUTHPIECE FOR THE TERROR
GROUP.
GO ON DRIVE BYES AND SPILL
ALL THEIR BLOOD SHE TWEETED
OR RENT A BIG TRUCK AND
DRIVE ALL OVER THEM.
KILL THEM.
SHE CLAIMS ISIS TOOK OVER
HER TWITTER ACCOUNT AND NOW
WITH THERAPY SHE CAN BECOME
A MODEL CITIZEN.
>> I HAVE NEVER DONE ANY
CRIME AND I'M SURE I AM NOT
GOING TO BE DOING ANY CRIMES
IN THE FUTURE.
AND I KNOW I HAVE COME TO
SYRIA AND LOOK LIKE I
SUPPORTED [INAUDIBLE]
>> SHE DENIES THAT SHE ONLY
FLED THE CALIPHATE BECAUSE
IT FELL.
HER TWEETS AND THE TIMELINE
SUGGEST OTHERWISE U AND IN
THE EYE US OF THE STATE